et pour en parler nous sommes avec eux
des nains mohammedi chercheur en
géopolitique bonsoir aden mohammedi
merci d'être avec nous les troupes du
président bachar qui ont repris le
contrôle de la ceinture de localités
entourant la ville d'alep
quelle est la portée déjà de cette
information
il y a une portée stratégique avec la
reprise de comme le signalait votre
votre collègue delà de l'autoroute 25
entre l'autoroute qui relie damas à alep
et il ya une portée aussi symbolique
c'est à dire la reconquête du nord ouest
se poursuit en dépit des objections turc
c'est une étape décisive ce grand vous
oui parce que de toutes les manières
sachant qu' il ya encore une présence
américaine résiduelles au nord-est du
pays le nord-ouest
aujourd'hui est l'ultime poche rebelle
ultime poche jihadistes pour le l'ultime
poche de djihadistes qui commande qu'ils
résistent encore à la reconquête uriel
c'est alors la recontre loyalistes est
menée par d'un côté l'armée syrienne et
de l'autre par l'armée russe qui a
soutenu largement cette reconquête
notamment sur le plan aérien alors le
président bachar qui s'est engagé
aujourd'hui justement poursuivre cette
offensive dans le nord-ouest du pays
pour je cite libéré l'ultime grand
bastion tenu par les djihadistes et les
rebelles est ce qui a encore beaucoup de
travail ce que ça va durer longtemps
oui alors là la région d'alep a été
libéré la ville d'alep est libérée
depuis la fin de l'année 2016
le principal noeud aujourd'hui pour la
reconquête loyalistes c'est la région
d'idleb
et c'est la ville d'idleb alors d'autant
que dans la ville d'idleb ont à faire un
groupe djihadiste
qui s'est montré efficace d'un point de
vue militaire jusque là je pense à
tahrir le cheikh donc cette organisation
issue d'al qaïda donc si le lien
aujourd'hui n'est plus revendiquer donc
oui alors il ya ce n'est évidemment ce
ne j'ai envie de dire opérationnel
militaire il ya aussi le noeud
diplomatique politique c'est la position
de la turquie parce que la turquie qui
ne soutient pas le seul groupe
djihadiste ne veut pas d'une poursuite
de cette reconquête socialiste pour des
raisons j'ai envie de dire à la fois
géopolitique parce qu'elle veut se
laisser une zone tampon pour ces pour
ses protégés et pour des raisons
humanitaires parce que la turquie
c'est un risque à un nouvel afflux de
réfugiés en cas de poursuite de la
reconquête loyalistes évidemment en face
les arguments des russes et du pouvoir
syrie nations là on reproche à la
turquie de ne pas avoir sécurisé de ne
pas avoir parti de ne pas avoir sécurisé
une zone qu'elles étaient censées en
partir et sécurisé je pense aux accords
de sotchi de septembre 2018
et lors de ces accords la turquie était
quand même censé sécuriser notamment
cette autoroute comme ça qu elle ne l'a
pas fait le cessez le feu
pas respectés par respecter sachant en
plus que les protégés de la turquie
c'est à dire ce qu'on appelait ce qu'on
appelle l'armée nationale syrienne ce
qu'on a appelé le front national de
libération
7 les protégés de la turquie ont perdu
face au destin c'est ça aussi il ne faut
pas l'oublier que c'est aussi parce que
les groupes jihadistes ont pris le
pouvoir dans cette zone ont pris le
pouvoir il est bon qu'on là qu'on a à
faire à cette situation particulièrement
difficile et l'autre grande difficulté
pour moi c'est peut-être la principale
difficulté c'est que contrairement aux
précédentes reconquête
qu'il s'agisse d'alep nodar le sud de la
jota de damas il n'y a plus de zone de
repli c'est à dire que les groupes
rebelles qu'on a viré par exemple
d'allah sont sortis de dallas avec des
accords de cessez-le-feu négocié avec la
russie et se sont retrouvés aujourd'hui
à idleb
après il n ya plus rien il ya plus on va
pas leur proposer une nouvelle nouveau
refuge
donc c'est une difficulté aux essais à
prononce montre comment peut-on en
sortir désormais je pense qu'ils
faudra encore attendre la l'armée
syrienne a bien avancé dans la région
d'alep
il y a une dizaine de jours l'armée
syrienne a fait une avancée majeure dans
la province d'idleb
je pense notamment à une ville qui
faisait la jonction entre les deux
principales art
les deux principales routes de la région
les autoroutes cannes 4e 5
l'un je pense qu'ils sont en train de se
calmer il est si on réfléchit un peu à 7
sur aussi on repense un peu ou pas ces
deux sets avant cette offensive
loyalistes dans la région
on se rend compte que elle se fait par
à-coups ses terres que la russie veille
au grain elle ne veut pas d'une foncier
loyalistes total tout simplement parce
que la turquie
brandy brandit sa ligne rouge et donc je
pense que là il ya en ce moment des
négociations entre la russie et la
turquie justement ou pas au sujet de la
ddt
je pense qu'il y ait dans les prochaines
semaines il va y avoir un petit
ralentissement des deux fonds d'ubs
royalistes autre symbole aéroports des
lettres qui va rouvrir aux vols
commerciaux c'est une première depuis
bien longtemps depuis 2012
qu'est ce que ça dit sachant que halep
et l'un des poumons économique
évidemment allait péter était la
capitale
du nord du pays c'était un grand pôle
industriel c'est peut-être l'un des
principaux pôles industriels de la
région depuis la guerre c'est une ville
qui a été fragilisée affaibli donc
l'objectif de la syrie et de sons de son
partenaire russe c'est de relancer
l'activité économique dans la région
parce que l'obsession aujourd'hui de
moscou avant même la reconstruction
politique avant même de poursuivre les
travaux d'astana c'est la reconstruction
matérielle et qui dit reconstruction
matérielle dit l'activité économique
donc de ce point de vue c'est une
victoire assez importante effective et
la reconstruction oui parce que 900
mille déplacés depuis décembre ce sont
des chiffres donnés par l'onu dans le
nord ouest syrien qu'est-ce que vous
évoque ces chiffres c'est une
catastrophe humanitaire à ces qui
j'allais dire qui ne dit pas son nom des
sites mais je pense que les russes ont
réussi un peu cet exploit jeudi entre
guillemets de façon un peu un peu
cynique de comment dire de détaler de la
catastrophe humanitaire pour qu'elle ne
soit pas aussi visible qu'à l'époque de
l'attak de l'offensive d'alep à la fin
de l'année 2016 donc en fait on a des
catastrophes humanitaires parakou où
kiné qui est beaucoup moins médiatisé
par exemple qu'à l'époque d'afrique pour
la population aux kurdes aussi parce que
idleb
ce site beaucoup moins d'émotion parce
que c'est une ville contrôlée par des
djihadistes universellement considérée
comme des terroristes on l'a pas là
affaire à des rebelles voix des modérés
ce sont des djihadistes et aux
nations-unies sont considérés comme des
terroristes
donc oui
et je pense que la russie qui se
préoccupe beaucoup plus de sons de sa
réputation qu'à l'époque beaucoup des
buts sur l'intervention entre 2015 et
2016 la russie pouvait se permettre de
tourner le dos aux commentaires au
regard aujourd'hui maintenant que la
russie à gagner militairement sur le sol
syrien la russie se préoccupe de sa
réputation de son image et donc veut
éviter les catastrophes humanitaires
d'ailleurs la russie a ouvert un certain
nombre de couloirs
aujourd'hui le ministère de la défense
aujourd'hui annoncé l'ouverture d'un
certain nombre de couloirs de corridor
humanitaire pour permettre aux civils de
quitter de quitter la ville sachant que
l'armée syrienne est à une dizaine de
kilomètres venant de la ville
donc oui je pense que ce qui ce qui a
aussi changé du côté loyaliste c'est
cette fois du côté russe surtout parce
que le pouvoir syrien a d'autres
préoccupations
c'est d'éviter
d'éviter une catastrophe humanitaire
trop visible trop ostentatoire comme à
l'époque d'alep uniquement pour l'image
où il ya des vrais résultats quand même
sur le terrain il ya beaucoup de choses
derrière fois il ya d'un côté l'image
évidemment parce que la réputation de la
réussite en jeu sur la scène
internationale il ya aussi la volonté de
rassurer les éventuels partenaires
arabes susceptibles de revenir et de
participer à la reconstruction du pays
la russie compte sur des sur les pays de
la région pour l'aider à reconstruire le
pays compte aussi sur des puissances
plus grands thèmes je pense à l'inde à
la chaîne donc il y à cet aspect il y à
aussi la relation qui est pour moi une
la relation capital relation central de
cette de cette huitième étape du conflit
c'est la relation entre la russie et la
turquie
alors évidemment on exagère toujours
dans les deux sens fois on exagère la
lie la proximité entre turcs et russes
en parlant à tort d'alliance soit on
exagère en parlant à tort de rupture dès
qu'il ya un accrochage entre l'armée
syrienne et l'armature je pense que en
ce moment il y à des transactions entre
la russie et la turquie et ses
transactions ou concerne à la fois le
nord-ouest et le nord-est
c'est à dire la fameuse zone de sécurité
obtenu par la turquie et qui pourrait se
transformer demain
merci beaucoup à l'ena mohammedi nous
avoir apporté votre éclairage